[Música]
hostigar al periodismo independiente
casos así abundan en Centroamérica y el
Caribe El hecho más reciente ocurrió en
Guatemala donde condenaron a Rubén
Zamora a seis años de cárcel él es el
fundador de el periódico y lo condenaron
por lavado de activos el manejo de
dinero también ha sido una causa contra
periodistas en las vecinas El Salvador y
Nicaragua y tanto en este último país
como en Cuba han aprobado leyes que
restringen a los medios de comunicación
qué tan golpeada está la libertad de
prensa en la región para responder a
esta y otras preguntas hoy en el debate
de France 24 nos acompaña desde Córdoba
Argentina Carlos journet presidente de
la comisión de libertad de prensa e
información de la sociedad
Interamericana de prensa sip y en Berlín
está juanpier subdirector para las
Américas de Human wright a ellos les doy
la bienvenida y a ustedes nuestra
audiencia Los invito a que dejen sus
comentarios y preguntas en las redes
sociales con el hashtag el debate f24
estamos en Twitter Facebook e Instagram
como arroba France 24 raya al piso es y
yo estoy en Twitter como arroba María
Clara Aguirre Los invito también a que
escuchen nuestro programa en las
plataformas de Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
quiero dar la bienvenida primero a
Carlos Gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros Cómo entender el caso más
reciente y la condena contra Rubén
Zamora en Guatemala
Buenas tardes cómo les va Bueno
realmente creo que sin duda alguna es un
caso que ha intentado silenciar a la
prensa que ha intentado Establecer un
esquema de protección para el presidente
Alejandro giant mattei y para sus
funcionarios es una estrategia que ha
venido desarrollándose en forma
paulatina pero sin pausa alguna desde
antes incluso de la detención de José
Rubén y que ha continuado luego con la
decisión del tribunal electoral de ir
poniendo trabas Para algunas
candidaturas políticas para las
elecciones del próximo domingo Así que
claramente entendemos que es un caso de
de una forma de amedrentar a la prensa
de ir contra Zamora pero para enviar un
mensaje claro al resto del periodismo
independiente de Guatemala y la prueba
está en que muchos colegas han tenido
que dejar el país han tenido que ir
hacia el exilio para poder proteger sus
vidas y su libertad personal y el exilio
es una de las modalidades que
analizaremos en este debate pero antes
le quiero dar la bienvenida a Juan
papier gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
el debate señor Fabián la primera
pregunta es cómo entender esta condena
contra Zamora y si usted nos puede
hablar del cargo por el que lo
condenaron que es lavado de activos
mientras que él afirma que precisamente
recibía donaciones que iban para el
periódico y que eran de personas
anónimas pues no querían que el gobierno
de Alejandro yamatei lo estuviera en el
radar como donantes de este medio
María Clara Muchas gracias por la
invitación con el caso de José Rubén
Zamora Hay que ser muy claro aquí el
Ministerio Público la fiscalía
guatemalteca no ha intentado Investigar
una transacción económica aquí lo que
han querido es perseguir a José Rubén
Zamora para silenciarlo para terminar
con sus investigaciones sobre corrupción
y abuso de poder en Guatemala y la
demostración de ello Es que no Solo han
investigado a José Rubén Zamora le han
pedido 40 años de cárcel han investigado
a sus abogados han investigado a los
periodistas del periódico que
escribieron sobre el caso e incluso le
han abierto nuevas causas penales con
argumentos espurios por ejemplo de que
él habría falsificado su propia firma en
los formularios de aduanas que uno tiene
que firmar al ingresar al país creo que
todo esto deja claro que como decía
Carlos Aquí no hay una causa penal seria
investigada de forma independiente y
parcial sino un esfuerzo por Enviar un
mensaje a la prensa independiente
Guatemala de que si pudieron ir contra
José Rubén Zamora pueden ir contra
cualquier otro y por lo tanto los
periodistas pretenden amendrarlo
amedrentarlos y que no puedan publicar
sus investigaciones sobre corrupción y
abuso de poder y este mensaje no es
exclusivo de Guatemala Juan ya que
también por casos relacionados con
dinero están investigando al editor del
faro en El Salvador Oscar Martínez y a
Carlos Fernando Chamorro el periodista
de El confidencial en Nicaragua Cómo o
qué tan utilizada es en la región la
presión de cargos vinculados con dinero
para perseguir a la prensa independiente
es un patrón que estamos viendo
crecientemente en Centroamérica no solo
los casos que mencionas del faro y de
Carlos Fernando Chamorro Nicaragua
también en Guatemala hay otros casos
donde se está utilizando la legislación
en contra de lavado de dinero para
intimidar a los periodistas para
requerirles una cantidad de información
excesiva que hace muy difícil que los
medios independientes puedan desempeñar
su trabajo creo que es un patrón
relativamente reciente en la región en
el que intentan criminalizarlos con
causas que para la ciudadanía son
difíciles de entender y buscan no solo
silenciarlos sino dañar su reputación
hacerle creer a la ciudadanía que estas
son personas
oscuras corruptas opacas cuando en
realidad se trata de periodistas
independientes que intentan hacer su
trabajo para que los ciudadanos puedan
conocer la verdad de lo que ocurre en
sus países Juan usted dice que esta es
una modalidad reciente Le quiero
preguntar a Carlos si desde la cip han
identificado un patrón similar en Casos
anteriores o de tiempo atrás sobre todo
vinculados con el dinero
sí claramente como decía el Corea es una
práctica que se viene extendiendo tal
vez Venezuela llevó a la práctica con
mucha intensidad y Eso terminó
prácticamente con todo vestigio de
periodismo Independiente el gobierno de
Nicaragua sigue el mismo camino en El
Salvador ocurre otro tanto y Guatemala
con este caso y otros más como bien se
señalaba recién que está recorriendo ese
mismo camino
muchas veces se nos dice que bueno si
hay un delito civil Por qué no de ir
contra un periodista que Cuál es el
fuero especial que tiene de ningún modo
planteamos eso no planteamos que un
periodista no pueda ser juzgado por
haber cometido delitos comunes Pero
tenemos sobrados motivos para sospechar
que en este y otros casos no se
garantiza el debido proceso no se
garantiza el derecho de defensa y además
hay un sesgo evidente de las autoridades
actuantes en la etapa de investigación
en la y en la descendencia personalmente
estuve en Guatemala junto al presidente
de la cip y al director ejecutivo en
diciembre pasado pudimos conversar con
las
fiscal especial Consuelo porras con
Cynthia monterroso que era la fiscal que
llevaba adelante el caso con José Rafael
curruchiche con el vicepresidente de la
República bueno estuvimos con
funcionarios con
representantes de la prensa y de otros
sectores políticos y sociales y
claramente hemos visto que había una
intención de perseguir a un periodista
de hacerle pagar por investigaciones que
había llevado adelante y de ir con él
a toda Costa decir se persiguió sus
abogados se los obligó a a renunciar a
la defensa se le imputaron a él a otros
periodistas del mismo periódico una
serie de causas que como bien se decía
recién son muy
de probar y además con pruebas que son
totalmente
fraguadas inventadas es decir no hay una
prueba sólida que se pueda llevar
adelante y por lo tanto tampoco hay una
prueba sólida a la cual se pueda rebatir
Es decir la defensa se hace muy difícil
cuando las pruebas que se aportan son
totalmente
amañadas Pero además con una fiscal que
las lleva adelante con una ironía con
una forma de plantear los temas y con un
juez como ocurrió por lo menos en la
etapa que fuimos nosotros a Guatemala
que claramente decía que sí a todo
porque sabía que detrás estaba el poder
político decir para nadie es una
sorpresa que la fiscal general Consuelo
porras es un brazo del poder político
para proteger el presidente y para ir
contra los opositores y el periodismo
independiente y usted habla de pruebas
no lo suficientemente argumentadas o
incluso pruebas inventadas Como cuáles
bueno concretamente en este caso el
delito de lavado de dinero
se planteó a partir de la denuncia de
una persona una persona que tenía además
antecedentes penales
una denuncia que después se hizo un
secuestro de dinero que no fue
debidamente
cumpliendo las formas legales que hay
que cumplir para iniciar un proceso y
cada cosa que se rebatía cada defensa
que se interponía primero venía la
presión sobre los abogados para que
renunciaran y después se descalificaban
esas pruebas se las dejaba de lado decir
ni siquiera se le permitió a José Rubén
Zamora leer la carta final en el momento
en que él iba a ser condenado que es el
mínimo que se exige en un proceso penal
por lo tanto claramente vemos que hubo
una intencionalidad desde el comienzo de
llevarlo a la cárcel y de que
fundamentalmente el periódico dejara de
existir como tal de hecho en noviembre
del año pasado dejó de salir su edición
impresa y en mayo de este año tuvo
también que suspender su edición online
o en internet con lo cual ya no es una
voz que pueda expresar una visión
distinta de la que lleva adelante el
presidente Alejandro yamate y todo esto
insistimos a muy pocos días ahora llega
la condena muy pocos días de él las
elecciones presidenciales en la que se
debe elegir al sucesor de Alejandro
yamatei él no puede ir por la reelección
pero evidentemente Quieren poner a un
delfín para que vaya adelante y pueda
proteger todo lo que se haya realizado
en este en esta gestión sin embargo del
otro lado el presidente de guatemalteco
Alejandro yamatei ha dicho que los
periodistas no son exentos de cumplir la
ley y ha justificado la condena contra
José Darío Zamora José Rubén Zamora
diciendo que el violentó las normas y
que por ello debe pagar este discurso
qué tan verace es Juan papier y si se ha
replicado en otros países
centroamericanos y del Caribe
mira lo que ocurre en Guatemala es que
las instituciones judiciales están
cooptadas hemos visto un proceso poco
transparente y poco Imparcial de
selección de la corte de
constitucionalidad estamos ante una
Corte Suprema que tiene muchos jueces
tienen su plazo vencido Hace cuatro años
Estamos ante una fiscal general que ha
actuado
como un brazo ejecutor para perseguir a
periodistas para Fiscales y jueces
independientes un procurador de Derechos
Humanos que no ha mostrado ninguna
independencia de la rama ejecutiva
Entonces es esperable que el presidente
quiera escudar detrás de la separación
de poderes pero lo que ocurre Es que hoy
tristemente esa separación de poderes no
existe en Guatemala estamos en un país
que está al borde de la deriva
autoritaria
y me parece que el caso de José Rubén
Zamora es un buen ejemplo de ello
Lamentablemente en otros países de la
región también está esta tendencia de
excusarse detrás de una separación de
poderes que la práctica no existe como
ocurre en Nicaragua como ocurre en
Venezuela donde los críticos son
condenados por los jueces son
perseguidos por los fiscales que en el
fondo no actúan de forma independiente
sino que responden a los intereses del
gobernante de turno usted apunta a un
factor fundamental y dice que en
Guatemala casi no hay separación de
poderes y que esto está limitando la
libertad de prensa en ese país sin
embargo hay otras naciones vecinas que
atraviesan también una difícil situación
en materia de libertad de expresión como
Nicaragua y El Salvador al respecto por
ejemplo bola dice que si bien la hay una
captación de poderes en los tres países
la diferencia es que en Guatemala esta
captación no está encarnada o en una
familia como es el caso de Nicaragua o
en una única persona como es el caso del
presidente nayib bukele qué otras
diferencias nota usted Juan papier entre
estos tres países en materia de libertad
de prensa
ese argumento es Es correcto en
Nicaragua y en El Salvador tenemos un
líder o una familia que gobierna el país
y que tristemente los trata como si
fuera su finca privada en Guatemala lo
que ocurre es que hay un oligopolio de
distintos actores del sector político
del sector militar Y también del sector
privado que gobiernan el país y que no
aceptan la división de poderes la
separación de poderes que es fundamental
para una democracia
Nicaragua es una dictadura es lo más
parecido que tenemos en nuestro
hemisferio Corea del Norte ahí a
cualquiera que critique que se aparte un
centímetro de lo que dice el régimen
puede ser perseguido puede ser
judicializado o forzado al exilio El
Salvador es un país donde el presidente
nayib bukele cabalga sobre su
popularidad una popularidad enorme y la
ha utilizado para destruir la separación
de poderes la democracia de una forma
muy parecida a la que lo la hizo Hugo
Chávez en su gobierno que llevó a
Venezuela la situación de Dictadura en
la que vive hoy son fenómenos distintos
pero en el fondo son parecidos Guatemala
Nicaragua y El Salvador porque los tres
hay una destrucción del Estado de
derecho que pone en riesgo los derechos
de todos sus habitantes y por trasladar
esas afectaciones al Estado de derecho
de las que habla Juan Le quiero
preguntar Carlos si puede hablarse de un
modus operandi para atacar a la prensa
en estos tres países Centroamericanos
porque digamos que vemos coincidencias
por ejemplo allanamientos a medios de
comunicación
investigaciones por supuesto lavados de
dinero congelación de las cuentas de los
medios de comunicación que obligan a su
cierre y posteriormente encarcelamientos
y Quienes se libran de los
encarcelamientos muchas veces terminan
exiliados como está pasando con
periodistas del Salvador de Nicaragua
que están en este momento en Costa Rica
se puede hablar de un modo súper amplio
sí claramente hay una metodología que se
reitera que se ha ido perfeccionando
porque los primeros esbozos de esta
forma de trabajar contra la prensa los
pusieron en marcha los populismos de
comienzo de este siglo de concretamente
Hugo Chávez en Venezuela Rafael Correa
en Ecuador
bueno los en Argentina
perdón de Evo Morales en Bolivia y luego
otros populismos de derecha o de
izquierda como el caso del propio Jair
bolsonaro en Brasil fueron
perfeccionando este mecanismo pero que
lo llevó a una instancia superior ha
sido sin duda Daniel Ortega en Nicaragua
que en una arremetida violenta contra la
prensa y contra otras instituciones que
de algún modo podían controlar a su
gobierno avanzó en plena pandemia entre
el 2020 y el 2021 para arrasar con toda
expresión crítica de su gobierno esa
metodología es la que están siguiendo la
que están llevando adelante nayib bukele
en El Salvador y Alejandro yamatei en
Guatemala claro cada país es distinto
cada mandatario tiene un una forma de
ejercer el poder distinta porque también
tiene condicionantes Alejandro yamatei
no ha ido por su reelección seguramente
no tenía la fuerza suficiente para dar
ese
zarpazo final contra las instituciones
pero claramente desde el comienzo ha
intentado ir degradando las
instituciones ha ido poniendo fiscal un
una fiscal general un fiscal especial
contra la impunidad que le fueron
totalmente
facilitadores de su de su impunidad y
que claramente permitieron también que
se pueda ir adelante contra Zamora en
este caso pero contra otros medios de
comunicación hemos recibido denuncias de
medios también del interior de Guatemala
que son poseídos por alcaldes por
funcionarios departamentales y por el
crimen organizado que una vez que desde
la máxima autoridad del país se da vía
libre para ir contra el periodismo cada
uno empieza a arremeter de distintas
formas usted menciona algo fundamental y
es que esta persecución a los medios se
da en populismos de izquierda y de
derecha y ha mencionado a diferentes
gobiernos Juan usted coincide con este
punto Y qué hace que ahora haya Digamos
como un auge de mayor persecución en
Centroamérica
coincido plenamente aquí Este no es un
tema de derecho de izquierda Este es un
tema de si estamos ante gobiernos
democráticos que creen en libertad de
prensa en la libertad de expresión o
ante gobiernos autoritarios como el caso
del Salvador o Guatemala o dictaduras
como las de Venezuela Cuba y Nicaragua
aquí la distinción no es derecho de
izquierda sino sobre compromiso con los
valores fundamentales de la Democracia o
el rechazo a estos valores creo que la
libertad de prensa tristemente está
amenazada por los cuatro costados en
nuestro continente cada vez son menos
los líderes que salen a defender a los
periodistas que entienden que su rol es
proteger más a los periodistas que sean
más críticos y que entienden que ahí
está la piedra angular de nuestras
democracias eso es lo que garantiza que
los ciudadanos puedan tomar decisiones
informadas que se pueda prevenir la
corrupción que se puedan garantizar
muchos derechos de la ciudadanía Creo
que este este retroceso que vemos en la
libertad de prensa pone en enorme riesgo
nuestras democracias en la región y que
tan frágiles están ahora las democracias
de América Latina sobre todo
Centroamérica y el Caribe le preguntó a
Carlos
nosotros vemos con mucha preocupación la
deriva autoritaria que ha ido tomando
buena parte de de Centroamérica y
también de América del Sur con gobiernos
que no defienden las libertades en
general la de prensa en particular pero
otras libertades también son van cayendo
van siendo Víctimas de regímenes
autoritarios personalistas claramente
dirigidos a perpetuarse en el poder
aunque no siempre lo logran y como
decíamos recién no es una cuestión de
ideologías sino de compromiso con las
libertades con la democracia con las
instituciones con el respeto a la
división de poderes hay gobernantes que
expresamente han dicho que no creen en
la división de poderes que la división
de poderes es una cuestión anticuada una
cuestión totalmente fuera de época y que
hoy los gobiernos necesitan ser fuertes
para dar
a las sociedades y por eso hablan de que
aquel todo aquel que cuestione esta
mirada absolutista es un enemigo del
pueblo entre ellos la prensa usted habla
de la falta de división de poderes Y eso
lo hemos visto por ejemplo en países
donde El Ejecutivo tiene mayorías en el
legislativo y eso ha hecho y ha
permitido que por ejemplo en Nicaragua
en el 2020 se aprobara la ley de
ciberdelitos a la que los opositores le
llamaban como ley mordaza porque lo que
hacía era que le daba cárcel a quienes
difundieran información supuestamente
falsa y ahora el hecho más reciente
ocurrió en Cuba porque en mayo en el
último mayo aprobaron la ley que prohíbe
los medios independientes y que permite
que únicamente existan medios que sean
avalados o por el estado o por
asociaciones reconocidas que normalmente
son progobierno o que sean medios
comunitarios Juan qué tanto Impacto
tienen en los medios de la región esta
clase de leyes
Creo que estas clases de leyes ponen en
riesgo la libertad de prensa en varios
países de la región lo que vemos en Cuba
es el comportamiento típico de una
dictadura que prohíbe todo tipo de
periodismo independiente y en el que
gracias a unos pocos periodistas que
operan con enorme valentía en el país
podemos conocer algunas de las cosas que
ocurren en la isla Lamentablemente
muchos de ellos han tenido que salir
exiliados en las últimas horas
represivas que vimos desde las protestas
de junio
de julio de hace dos años tenemos
legislación similarmente Abusiva en
Nicaragua en Venezuela
leche leches problemáticas para la
libertad de expresión en otros países de
la región son Son normas que en algunos
casos intentan ahogar a los periodistas
a través de su financiamiento que en
otros los catalogan como agentes
extranjeros para impedir su
funcionamiento en el país o que crean
tipos penales crímenes tan amplios que
ponen en riesgo el funcionamiento de los
periodistas porque ellos temen Con razón
que pueden ser judicializados con este
tipo de delitos como ocurrió con la ley
de ciberdelito en Nicaragua Carlos Cuál
es su opinión sobre cuál es impacto el
impacto de estas leyes y también del
exilio logran acallar a la prensa
no yo creo que hay periodistas que
quieren seguir haciendo periodismo
incluso desde fuera de las fronteras de
su propio país como ha ocurrido
Nicaragua y muchos colegas nicaragüenses
que siguen informando desde Costa Rica
desde Estados Unidos desde México decir
van trasladándose y tratando de mantener
contacto con sus fuentes aunque esto no
es sencillo cuando uno no está en el
propio territorio Pero la idea esta de
plasmar un clima de restricción un
efecto desalentador sobre la libertad de
expresión en general creo que tiene una
enorme resistencia los periodistas
siguen demostrando su valentía el hecho
de que en Cuba después de seis décadas
de de un gobierno que de ningún modo
defiende la libertad de expresión aún
así sigue habiendo periodistas que
quieran ejercer el periodismo y que lo
realizan a través de la plataforma que
sea tratando de conectarse a en Las
Plazas en las en las calles para poder
subir una nota postear un un hacer un
posteo en alguna de las redes sociales
evidentemente quiere decir que la
libertad Sigue estando viva Pero
evidentemente
todo este tipo de presiones van
restringiendo la posibilidad de que las
sociedades se informen y que sobre todo
se expresen y puedan poner un freno al
avance autoritario pero tal como usted
lo plantea esta defensa de la libertad
de prensa sería a Costa de una
restricción individual enorme porque
estamos hablando de periodistas que
están poniendo en riesgo su vida las de
sus familias que tienen que vivir en el
exilio y que aún en medio de todas estas
dificultades individuales siguen
intentando informar cómo encontrar el
equilibrio entre no ser o no sacrificar
toda su vida por esto de ser el Héroe de
la libertad de prensa Carlos
bueno claramente creo que la presión
internacional
el accionar de entidades como las que
Juan oyó representamos ayuda para que
esta voz siga estando viva que sigue
estando activa se sigue escuchando pero
evidentemente
las restricciones son enormes Muchos
medios han tenido que cerrar
definitivamente sus puertas recién se
hablaba de Nicaragua y las denuncias que
hizo el Gobierno de lavado de dinero
Bueno una de las denuncias fue contra
directivos y periodistas y personal de
conducción de la prensa de Nicaragua Y
eso llevó a que la prensa dejara de ser
un medio impreso y realmente le cueste
enormemente la subsistencia para poder
seguir informando prácticamente con
todas sus redacción desde el exterior
desde fuera de Nicaragua evidentemente
es una situación muy muy compleja para
estos países
de la sociedad Interamericana de prensa
Estamos buscando forma de ayudar de
capacitar de arrimarle herramientas para
que los periodistas puedan seguir
ejerciendo el periodismo pero la
restricción al acceso a las fuentes
informativas la el ahogo económico que
estos gobiernos
desencadenan contra todo aquel que
quiera expresar una voz crítica es
enorme y bueno esta multinacional de la
censura que hablábamos recién de
gobiernos que se van intercambiando
metodologías para asfixiar a la prensa
realmente es una batalla muy muy
compleja muy desigual pero creemos que
la libertad se va a seguir imponiendo y
que el pueblo va a seguir buscando
caminos alternativos para informarse y
para expresarse como lo sigue haciendo
el pueblo cubano y como lo demostró en
las protestas de hace dos años bueno
coincide o no usted en esta visión por
decirlo más optimista que tiene Carlos
de que a pesar de la presión y el
hostigamiento va a primar la libertad de
prensa y a pesar de que en países por
ejemplo como Guatemala se cierran medios
independientes como el periódico se
pueda lograr una libertad informativa
mira creo que hay que mantener el
optimismo porque aquí estamos ante
periodistas que son extremadamente
valientes que hacen su trabajo en
situaciones adversas que hacen su
trabajo A veces arriesgando su vida como
ocurre en México que es uno de los
países con el la tasa más alta de
homicidios de periodistas en todo el
mundo Qué hacen su trabajo desde el
exilio como ocurre con los periodistas
nicaragüenses guatemaltecos salvadoreños
es decir personas que realmente
arriesgan sus derechos fundamentales
para poder garantizar la información
fidedigna al público a la ciudadanía
pero para honrar este trabajo tan
valiente creo que es importante que la
comunidad internacional haga mucho más
por apoyar estos periodistas si los
gobiernos de Europa si los gobiernos si
el gobierno de Estados Unidos y los
otros gobiernos de América Latina tienen
un compromiso serio con la democracia
del Estado de derecho creo que una de
las mejores medidas que pueden hacer es
reforzar su apoyo a los periodistas
independientes en América Latina que
cumplen un rol crucial para garantizar
que que de democracia que quedan algunos
países de la región en otros queda algo
más pero que esta democracia pueda
seguir siendo vibrante y que la
ciudadanía pueda seguir
informándose sobre lo que ocurre en sus
países Ahora hasta ahora hemos hablado
digamos de dos choques o un choque
frontal entre dos actores un sistema
Estatal ya sea con El Ejecutivo el
legislativo y muchas veces hasta el
judicial contra los periodistas pero
digamos que ha habido otra modalidad que
se puede representar en el caso de
Panamá con el caso judicial conocido
como New business en el que se investiga
si el expresidente Ricardo martinelli
blanqueó dineros en la compra de la
editorial editora Panamá América Carlos
yo le quiero preguntar qué tanto se da
en Centroamérica esta modalidad de que
los poderosos y los políticos compren
medios de comunicación para cambiarlos
desde adentro
se da es una una práctica que se se va
repitiendo también así como el acoso
judicial es decir plantear demandas
enormes contra periodistas y medios de
comunicación para obligarlos a en el
caso de los medios a ir a la venta y en
el caso de los periodistas para
silenciarlos es decir el acoso judicial
es una práctica muy muy extendida en
América Latina y obviamente necesita
también de una complicidad del poder
judicial
bueno de algún modo esto se conecta con
el caso de José Rubén Zamora pero hay
otros casos de acciones judiciales
contra medios que solo buscan o
llevarlos a la venta o al cierre o en el
caso de los periodistas a la autocensura
periodistas que reciben una demanda
muchas veces millonarias
realmente no tienen posibilidades ni
siquiera de contratar a un abogado para
que los defienda y de ese modo el único
camino que le queda es recurrir a la
autocensura y cuando un periodista elige
ese camino que no lo cuestionamos en
modo alguno porque entendemos también
las difíciles circunstancias que deben
atravesar o presiones sobre sus familias
ciber de persecuciones
de formas de control de su vida Privada
de todo tipo evidentemente son
situaciones muy complejas que
censuran a un periodista y con él luego
van desencadenando en otros
actitudes semejantes de periodistas que
creen que ya no tienen forma de seguir
ejerciendo su periodismo en forma
independiente y libre Juan y cómo
entiende usted el caso New business en
Panamá se puede hablar de otra clase de
hostigamiento a la prensa
Mira los reportes del caso son muy
preocupantes no quiero pronunciarme
sobre los detalles Porque es un caso que
a la fecha no hemos documentado
debidamente como se ha ocurrido por
ejemplo con el caso de José Rubén Zamora
que que conocemos los detalles y cada
una de las acusaciones etcétera Pero sí
son reportes preocupantes porque lo que
necesitan nuestras democracias son
periodistas que pueden hacer su tarea
cumplir con su trabajo de forma libre
independiente tienen que ser
independientes de los gobiernos de turno
de las presiones de los gobiernos de
turno tienen que ser independientes de
las presiones de criminales o del crimen
organizado pero también independientes
de actores que quieran cooptarlos a
través de financiamiento espurio o a
través de este tipo de de maniobras como
las que mencionas en Panamá creo que lo
que necesita nuestra democracia son ese
tipo de periodistas que puedan actuar de
forma libre y por eso nos preocupa tanto
este este reporte reciente en Panamá y
ya para ir cerrando nuestro programa
Juan Le quiero preguntar cuál es su
conclusión precisamente sobre esa
Independencia en los medios y en los
periodistas de Centroamérica y el Caribe
que como lo hemos hablado durante todo
el programa presentan la situación más
crítica en este momento
creo que la democracia está en riesgo en
buena parte de los países de América
Latina en particular de Centroamérica y
el Caribe y una de las primeras Víctimas
de ese ataque a la democracia han sido
los periodistas y y lo han sido porque
ellos son quienes dejan al descubierto
la corrupción el abuso de poder las
violaciones derechos humanos que comen
los que cometen los gobernantes de turno
creo que aquí la comunidad internacional
tiene que cumplir un rol crucial como
decíamos para protegerlos porque
protegían a los periodistas se protege
la democracia de todos los ciudadanos de
nuestra región usted apunta a la
relación entre la democracia y a los
periodistas como las primeras víctimas
Carlos usted coincide en esta conclusión
y para añadirle cómo evalúo a usted la
actuación internacional en estos casos
protege o no lo suficiente a estos
periodistas
en realidad bueno el primer lugar sí
creo que cuando un gobierno quiere
arremeter contra las instituciones
tratar de ir concentrando poder lo
primero que hace habitualmente es Buscar
silenciar a la prensa para que no se
denuncien sus irregularidades para que
no haya
posibilidad de que los opositores
políticos tengan también una forma de
canalizar sus protestas sus denuncias
sus reclamos Pero además claramente
estos gobiernos una vez que arremeten
contra la prensa van contra el resto de
las instituciones
los gobiernos
de la región muchas veces silencien lo
que ocurre en países vecinos en algunos
casos hay hay pactos de no agresión
mutua y digo no agresión entre comillas
Pero además la comunidad internacional
pone sus ojos en América Latina muy
pocas veces porque no somos la región de
que marca el contexto general de
las relaciones políticas internacionales
entonces en la medida en que se logre
mantener el foco sobre estas cuestiones
la presión va a comenzar a ejercer su
función principal que es la de poner un
freno a estos arrebatos autoritarios
Lamentablemente
lo que ocurrió tiempo atrás con el
presidente Donald Trump en Estados
Unidos imitando alguna de estas
prácticas de confrontar permanentemente
con los medios de descalificarlos de
acusarlos de ser enemigos del del pueblo
norteamericano de algún modo terminó
avalando el accionar de estos gobiernos
populistas de la región Y eso se ha
extendido con mucha mayor velocidad e
intensidad si logramos que haya una
conciencia internacional de que libertad
no es un privilegio de solamente de los
países desarrollados sino que en todo el
mundo tiene que haber condiciones para
que la gente pueda expresarse con
libertad para que se puedan comunicar
sus las opiniones para que pueda haber
que no exista ningún tipo de
condicionamientos de para el ejercicio
de estas libertades esenciales del ser
humano la democracia sería consolidando
y el contexto internacional va a ser
mucho más
proclive para que haya una
libertad generalizada y un marco de
pacificación General en la medida en que
una región caiga nuevamente en prácticas
antidemocráticas de no haber crecimiento
económico no va a haber sociedades que
puedan retener a sus poblaciones bueno
buena parte de las migraciones que
estamos viviendo en el Continente
vienen de esta realidad tan difícil que
viven países de Centroamérica en
especial pero también el resto del
continente vemos entonces como ante la
mirada que no se enfoca necesariamente
en Centroamérica y el Caribe como bien
lo explica Carlos Está aumentando
también en medio de los populismos que
hay en la región tanto de izquierda y
derecha aumenta la persecución contra la
libertad de prensa Carlos jornet y Juan
papier gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
el debate Y ustedes nuestra audiencia
Gracias por sintonizarnos yo les
agradezco en nombre de todo el equipo
técnico la producción del debate estuvo
a cargo de Andrés doncell y la de los
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera Los
invito a que sigan conectados a flash 24
[Música]